I've got some bad news and some good
news the bad news is that there's yet
another grifter taking advantage of the
umah the umah the community of
Muhammad's followers is in panic mode
because of the Avalanche of apostasy
they're looking around for something
they can cling to and grifters and con
artists of all sorts Andrew Tate sneo
and now Lily Jay have been lining up to
manipulate this desperate Community
that's the bad news the good news is
that Lily Jay the latest grifter taking
advantage of the umah accidentally
proved that Jesus is Muhammad's God I
don't know which dawa clowns are writing
her scripts for her but it seems they
forgot to warn her about Sherk if you're
not familiar with Lily J her videos
became popular when she realized chat
GPT could be told to give Islamic
answers to questions and then in her
videos she would ask chat GPT questions
and be shocked that the answers support
Islam and of course her Muslim viewers
would eat it up so how did Lily Jay
accidentally prove that Jesus is
Muhammad's God it all started when she
was trying to impress her followers by
using chat GPT to find Muhammad in the
Bible so chb is there any other verses
in the Bible that our about Prophet
Muhammad yes in John 14:16 Jesus says
and I will pray the father and he shall
give you another comforter that may
abide with you
forever John 14 verse 16 let's go ahead
and read the verse John 14:16 Jesus says
and I will ask the father and he will
give you another helper to be with you
forever notice that Jesus refers to the
father here
do Muslims refer to Allah as father no
they don't because according to the
Quran Allah is a father to No One not in
any sense so even before we consider the
meaning of the verse we see that it
already contradicts Islam and it gets
worse for Lily because if we go back
just three verses we find Jesus Calling
himself the son and claiming that after
he goes away he will answer the prayers
of his followers Jesus declares whatever
you ask in my name this I will do that
the father may be glorified in the son
if you ask me anything in my name I will
do it father and son Jesus answers
prayers is this starting to sound like
Islam yet strange how lily Jay left that
part out but we'll let her slide on all
of this because again she's about to
prove that Jesus is Muhammad's god let's
hear from chat GPT again in John 1416
Jesus says and I will pray the father
and he shall give you another comforter
that may abide with you forever isn't
this about the Holy Spirit I thought
Christians believe this was about the
Holy Spirit why do Christians claim that
Jesus is talking about the Holy Spirit
in John
14:16 let's see what Lily Jay leaves out
of her video John 14:
16-17 and I will ask the father and he
will give you another helper to be with
you forever even the spirit of Truth
whom the world cannot receive because it
neither sees him nor knows him you know
him for he dwells with you and will be
in you so Jesus Calls the helper the
spirit of Truth and if we keep de
reading down to verse 26 we find Jesus
saying but the helper the Holy Spirit
the Holy Spirit the Holy Spirit whom the
father will send in my name he will
teach you all things and bring to your
remembrance all that I have said to you
who does Jesus identify as the helper
the comforter who does Jesus say he's
talking about the Holy Spirit and now
notice what we have in this passage
father son Holy Spirit father son Holy
Spirit father son Holy Spirit this
entire passage is completely utterly
totally
trinitarian strange place to go to find
support for Muhammad and Islam so why
does Lily Jay once again leave out the
parts of the passage that contradict
Islam and the lies she's telling why
does she act like Christians are just
imagining that Jesus is talking about
the Holy Spirit when Jesus specifically
says that he's talking about the Holy
Spirit isn't this about the Holy Spirit
I thought Christians believe this was
about the Holy Spirit yes many
Christians interpret the comforter as
the Holy Spirit however some Muslims
believe this term could refer to Prophet
Muhammad considering certain
descriptions and prophecies
hm why do Christians believe that Jesus
is talking about the holy spirit because
Jesus says he's talking about the Holy
Spirit and Christians respect Jesus
enough to let him explain what he means
why do Muslims believe that Jesus is
talking about Muhammad when Jesus says
he's talking about the holy spirit
because they don't respect Jesus enough
to let him explain what he means they're
desperate to find some sort of support
for the most obvious false prophet in
history the da clowns and their puppet
Lily J know that Muslims are desperate
for something that confirms Muhammad as
a prophet and these grifters are all too
happy to lie about the Father the Son
and the Holy
Spirit a lot of Christians say this is
100% about the Holy Spirit again because
that's what Jesus said said and unlike
Lily we respect Jesus enough to believe
him when he explains what he means a lot
of Christians say this is 100% about the
holy spirit so I'm just going to have a
little research and get back to you guys
apparently Lily Jay's research didn't
involve you know actually reading the
passage her research consisted entirely
of reading the daas script that
whoever's paying her told her to
read okay so in John
167 it says it is for your own good that
I'm going away Jesus is saying to his
disciples I'm going away for your own
good not a good verse to be quoting if
you're trying to dupe people into
believing in Muhammad lily Jesus says
these words when he's just hours away
from his crucifixion Jesus tells his
followers that he's going away
he tells his followers that it's good
that he's going away he's going to die
for sins and rise from the dead he'll
return to his eternal glorified state
where he'll answer the prayers of his
disciples and he's not going to leave
them alone he's going to send the holy
spirit so the disciples shouldn't be sad
because this is for their good Jesus is
saying to his disciples I'm going away
for your own good because if I don't go
away The Advocate will not come wasn't
the Holy Spirit already there wasn't the
Holy Spirit already there Jesus says
that if he doesn't go away the helper
The Advocate the comforter won't come to
them but the Holy Spirit was already
there so Jesus must be talking about
someone else namely
Muhammad oh Lily is this really worth it
how much did they pay you to lie about
Jesus and the Holy Spirit let's look
once again at one of the verses you left
out we already read it but we'll go
ahead and start at John 14:16 again so
we can get the answer you somehow missed
even though it's in the very next verse
Jesus says and I will ask the father and
he will give you another helper to be
with you forever even the Spirit of
Truth whom the world cannot receive
because it neither sees him nor knows
him you know him for he dwells with you
and will be in you you know him for he
dwells with you and will be in you Lily
asks wasn't the Holy Spirit already
there yes and Jesus says that the helper
the spirit of Truth the Holy Spirit was
already with the disciples but
something's going to change when Jesus
goes away the helper the spirit of Truth
the holy spirit is going to be in them
so mystery solved Lily this doesn't
refute the Christian interpretation it
refutes the Muslim
interpretation Jesus identifies the
helper as the Holy Spirit and he says
that the helper is already with the
disciples but that he will soon indwell
the
disciples was Muhammad there with the
disciples no would Muhammad indwell the
disciples no is there any way this is
about Muhammad absolutely none
whatsoever but let's go back to the
verse Lily had on the screen but didn't
finish reading because well you'll see
Lily had John 167 on the screen let
let's read it Jesus says nevertheless I
tell you the truth it is to your
advantage that I go away for if I do not
go away the helper will not come to you
but if I go I will send him to you I
will send him to you I will send him to
you who sends the helper The Advocate
the comforter
Jesus does so Jesus sends the helper the
helper is sent by Jesus according to
Islam who sends
Muhammad who sends Muhammad as a prophet
according to
Islam Allah so Allah sends Muhammad
Muhammad is sent by
Allah are you getting this Jesus sends
the hel
the helper is sent by Jesus Allah sends
Muhammad Muhammad is sent by Allah so if
the helper is Muhammad as Lily J insists
who does that make
Jesus
hallelujah hallelujah hallelujah
hallelujah
hallu thank you Lily J for admitting
that Jesus is the god of Muhammad and
the god of Muslims everywhere in context
of course it's the father and the son
together who send the Holy Spirit as I
said this passage in John is completely
utterly totally trinitarian isn't it
strange that Lily Jay tries to convince
her viewers that Muhammad is the spirit
of
Truth seriously
Muhammad look at how lily J has to lie
over and over again about the father and
the Son and the Holy Spirit in order to
deceive her viewers into believing that
John 14:16 is about Muhammad if Muhammad
were the spirit of Truth would he need
an endless array of lies to support him
of course
not but Lily Jay also used chat GPT to
find Muhammad in Deuteronomy 18 where
God said that he would send a prophet
like Moses Lily claims that Muhammad was
the prophet like Moses unfortunately for
her my friend inspiring philosophy took
a closer look and found you guessed it
more lies from Lily be sure to check out
the video
[Music]